[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savoir donner et non pas des frères dont
on connaît on avait reconnu on sait qui
chante ça commence à marcher et à l'etap
hôtel
j'ai eu le bac mention non à bien à
bientôt
on vous rappelle dans la semaine quand
j'ai eu je comptais c'est beau sans
rigoler c'est bon moi je le nom pas de
mention wackenbach ici tout le monde est
debout et bah quoi ça vous a servi non
pas encore oh ben alors pas encore et
encore sur m6 on l'a peu près persuadé
qu'un choix d'un choix pourquoi c'est en
esthétique toi ouais hein tu faisais
quoi technique maquillage ouais si
filiation la surprise c'est vrai quoi si
la presse massée pour les merci merci
vous aimez ça va je suis pas chaud quand
on est là il ya les matchs russes qui
sont de retour
le tweeter d'une des personnalités de
ces huit lutteurs surveiller le twitter
d'une des personnalités de ces huit
c'est un ami m'appelle un animateur
ah oui c'est un animateur c'est qu'il
connaît vous le connaissez très bien
ah oui on serait plus dans un instant
oui william leymergie la paix et non non
aux animateurs on la nie maintenant
alors l'animateur
ah oui c'est ça leur passera pas l'hiver
elle voulait qu'on commence lorsque
quatre antennes et allez hop jamais
copié souvent égalé il fallait pas rater
à la télévision française ce week-end
mais très très très très très vite
regarde on commence en pologne avec la
compétition d'histoire les joueurs sont
hyper concentré l'entraîneur lui il
aurait quand même mieux fait de regarder
devant lui au derrière lui
[Musique]
on se voit ici à pascal obispo kahniens
vent catégorie 4 à nikos ils ont
enchaîné leur dorian nicolle ça passe
c'est quelque chose de puissant merci
maman que conversé vocaux qu'est ce
qu'elle dit cette chanson parce que
qu'est ce qu'elle nie cette chanson
mercier la chorale n'a pas entendu dans
ce laps taya qui a confié une amie
jusqu'à paris en espère enfin conclure
mais c'était friends au néant peine
parti et le vit mal vu bob et sylvie et
on a aussi loïc le chéri de joël qui est
l'annoncé votre avis il ne s'est pas le
chéri de joël attention
loïc est un ami de joël il est dégoûté
par les médias il appelait grâce à max
est venu y en belgique le sait ça
n'existe pas s'installer là bas avec
cyril où elle est là bas en fait de
regarder ça ressemble un petit peu un
lexique poids lui aussi aussi il peut
peut-être c'est pas si fréquent ryan
reynolds lecteurs de deadpool était de
passage à paris regarder qu'il a pris 1
celle qui maxime gagné
[Applaudissements]
mais rien est un truc qui nous sommes
pourraient converger mme beauchamp soit
votée le regard mais j'essaie de faire
attention à mon poids maintenant tu peux
respecter les gens respectent le mien
aussi
mais très bien par contre la moustache
tout va très bien non mr et d'autres qui
ressemble de plus en plus sa courbe est
un ouais c'est vrai lui aurait 32 es
dont deux mois il fait une pub pour des
fenêtres
je le dis ça à ce rythme là
samedi c'était quoi ca fait à ma droite
les a faites à mâcon taux varie bloqué h
est d'accord quarante mille manifestants
selon les organisateurs 14 selon la
police les chaînes infos étaient
mobilisés sur place qu'on a retenu
quelques trucs forcément on savait qu'il
ya plein de duplex toute la journée
déjà tout le monde craignait la vue de
casseurs sur place cité la grosse
crainte pour tout le monde et devinez du
cookie bfm a envoyé pour couvrir les
événements ne pouvait pas trouver mieux